for more on this I'm joined by elone
California mayor and Congressional
candidate Bill Wells Mr Mayor welcome
good morning what is your reaction to
the latest headlines you just heard from
the
border well you know a San Diego County
has 33,000 people dropped off in the
last two months with 169 people on the
terror watch list we're very concerned
not not only about what this is doing to
the infrastructure of San Diego which is
already overwhelmed by this homeless
crisis which is much larger in
California than anywhere else in the
nation but we're also worried about with
the war that's happening in Israel and
things being so stirred up in the Middle
East and anti-Semitism amazingly On The
Rise throughout the world we're very
concerned about people from Hamas coming
into California San Diego area and we're
worried about our Safety and Security
President Biden is proposing 20 miles of
movable border wall for South Texas um
frustrating both environmentalists and
those who want stronger security what do
you make of that well I I always thought
that the border wall was the smartest
thing that we could have done to uh help
the Border I'm glad uh that President
Biden is coming a little late to the
party but willing to do something in the
right the right direction we actually
should be securing our entire Southern
border with a not a movable border wall
but a permanent border wall the United
States right now has a huge problem with
fentel poisoning the American people
should President Biden bring that up
when he meet with Chinese president shei
this week absolutely we need to take a
hard line with China just the other
day which is just
a he was caught with 180 pounds of
fentol come in I don't know how many
people that could kill but certainly
every person in America that 180 pounds
is an amazing amount of fentanyl we've
got to stop this uh China is sending the
precursors to Mexico Mexico is the one
who producing it both Nations need to be
held accountable for what they're doing
to our citizens with over 100,000 young
people dying of fentanyl being the
number one killer of young people in
America right now in your view should
Alejandro maoris the Secretary of
Homeland Security be impeached this
week absolutely he should be imp he has
been lying blatantly to the American
public telling people that the border is
not open it's obviously open if you go
down to the Border even if you go to our
trolley stations in San County there is
no doubt that the border is wide open
and no enforcement's being done and no
vetting is being done we have no idea
who's coming in and we've seen over8
million people come in under President
Biden's watch that's an amazing number
of people and it will change the
complection of the United States for
decades to come Marcus's AIDS respond
that he's been doing his job while House
Republicans are trying to score
political points what do you think of
that my orcus is just a liar the you
know there's there's no way to say it
I'd like to be diplomatic about it but I
can't he is so rooted in ideology and a
political narrative and he has no
concern for doing his job or for
protecting the American people he's an
absolute liar and needs to
go Bill Wells mayor of elone California
grateful for your time today sir and uh
thanks very much for your analysis
thanks for having me hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else